you can be petting them and they'll just
all of a sudden bite you
what
there's
hi hello friend
[Music]
cats are just like
cats always hate me uh
so therefore i hate them back i don't
like them i don't like cats one bit
every cat i've met has has a distinct
dislike for me so you know what the
feeling's mutual i hate you their claws
are really creepy we can all agree on
that they do that little needy thing and
it really hurts
let's do this
they're probably not happy from being in
a box oh my god
there's so many inside
oh no no no no
[Music]
oh that was actually quite
cute hello
[Music]
i don't know how to do cats i don't know
how to play with a cat i don't know what
cats do my baby's more entertaining
tell me what's good about cats i feel
like i'm on a first date that's not
going well controlling them i feel like
a mom you're just gonna be like all
right i'm done with you holding me i'm
gonna claw the [ __ ] out of your face
right now i feel like that's coming they
may be cute and all
sweet but they're gonna turn on you he's
kind of small and adorable though okay
i guess
it's cute this is the cutest cat i've
ever seen in my entire life
[Music]
how can you not love something like this
how can you not look at this and just
melt some of them are mean but some of
them are cool still not as great as
puppies puppies are the best it takes a
particular type of person and that
person is not me they're like kind of
cute
i guess maybe i would get this one
this one that's sleeping
[Music]
[Music]